додому прийшла і похоронка і м'ясо на
кладбище вже все це було то есть вони
вже даже готовились для того щоб вони
скажем охоронити була поранена у нас
вижило Три чоловіка загиблі
Наші військовослужбовці і це все було на
очах поранений вже потратив потрапив нас
за сталь де отримав ще одне поранений в
ході прорив кожен із цих військових ЗСУ
проходить тривало і безкоштовно
реабілітацію в Одесі Утім медзакладів
кошти закінчуються а кількість поранених
які потребують допомоги зростає
рік тому Руслан потрапив під обстріл на
херсонському напрямку уламки снарядів
пробили військовому череп без медичної
допомоги Руслан пролежав 10 днів те що
він вижив справжнє диво
сказали дружині що я находжуся в лікарні
А це як 10 днів Моя дружина думала що я
загинув
у статусі полоненого у лікарні в
окупованому Херсоні Руслана прооперували
там він провів 5 місяців аж доки його
дружина Людмила не наважилася на
відчайдушний вчинок приїхала до
окупованого Херсона і вкрала чоловіка з
полону ми зінулися до завідувача щоб ці
документи вже переробити щоб написати не
міносколишнє А що це ДТП
село Тисів поміг нам написав у нас було
почувається дві випуски одна була якби
для нашого що зі мною случилося і для
них що це було ДТП
ще два місяці тому Руслан не міг сидіти
нині поволі вчиться знову стояти аби
повернутися до нормального життя
знадобиться близько року регулярних
занять із реабілітологом Утім центр у
якому відновлюють Руслана залишився
Майже без грошей на даний момент в нас
мабуть на рахунку десь 7 тисяч гривень
це Ну нічого
як ми будемо працювати далі Ну
незрозуміло Сергій ращенко безкоштовно
приймає українських військових у своєму
приватному медичному центрі нині тут
відновлюється близько 20 поранених
бійців як стали з’являться перші
пораненим ми прийняли рішення що ми
будемо допомагати
Я вважаю що я особисто вважаю що вони не
повинні ні за що платити
за них треба щоб платила держава але
зараз
цього механізму не існує тому ми
робимо це ну як можемо зараз в нас є
благодійний фонд ми збираємо якийсь там
кошти звертаємося до людей Вони і
донатять таким чином ми з цих коштів
оплачуємо роботу наших спеціалістів
так у фінансування для обслуговування
автомобіля який безоплатно возить
пацієнтів на реабілітацію він спеціально
обладнаний для того щоб можна було
перевозити людину у візку
в нас є водій в нас є
потреби утоплевії всіх матеріалах
потрібних ремонти такі інше страховка
наприклад
всі ці кошти в нас
давали Нам спонсори зараз цих спонсорів
майже немає нині Сергій веде перемови
потенційними спонсорами з усього світу і
вже є перші результати декілька компаній
міська 2 вона
пропонує нам вибрати декілька там
тренажерів які нам потрібні та доставити
нам їх безкоштовно ще ми ведемо
перемовини І що з декількома компаніями
інший реабілітаційний центр в Одесі
також безоплатно допомагає військовим
цей медзаклад Навіть уклав договір із
військовим медичною частиною бійцями
якої тепер опікується але жодних коштів
від держави не отримує адже офіційно
поранені числиться у військово-медичній
частині мають чи навіть договор з
національною службою здоров'я тобто
маючи право отримувати якісь кошти за
амбулаторну реабілітацію ми можемо цього
робити з військовослужбовцями бо в них є
вже лікарняні в своїх військових
частинах не можемо дублювати
ці послуги
з фондами також є проблеми тобто люди
більш радо дають гроші на озброєння чи
на автомобільну техніку ніж на
реабілітацію військовослужбовців на жаль
це факт тим не менше у центрі надалі
планують допомагати військовим адже тут
теж є сучасне обладнання може поставити
на ноги багатьох поранених якщо казати
про це обладнання яке в нас тут є воно
дозволяє працювати навіть в з перших
днів після травми та операції ми всі
розуміємо і лікарі там і ми тут і хлопці
які До нас приїжджають що надати такі
можливості як є у мене тут з такою
кількістю фізичних терапевтів ну ці
державні заклади на жаль на сьогоднішній
день не можуть ідеться не лише
про віднесі курс іпотерапії це метод
реабілітації за допомогою верхової їзди
на заняття проходять без сідла тобто
людини сідає на спину коня А ось і за
рахунок цього вона отримує
специфічного амплітуду а рухів і
коливань які робить кінь коли йде тобто
кінь сам по собі Він повторює ходу
людини Ось і в нього є ще коливання в
дуже різні сторони з боку в бік і
зверху вниз і назад вперед тобто Ось ця
загалом всі ці рухи ця амплітуда рухів
Вона має вплив і на центральну нервову
систему і на м'язи і на опорно-рухову
систему також наразі курс ліквідації
проходять 20 військовослужбовців
військово-морських сил
Віктор отримав поранення обороняючи порт
Маріуполя як поранений вже потратив
потрапив на застав де отримав ще одне
поранений в ході прориву медика Азову
надали першу медичну допомогу наскільки
це було Можливо тому що медикаментів вже
тоді не було рентгенів не було гіпса не
було під час виходу захисників за
зросталів Віктор потрапив у полон без
належної медичної допомоги у Донецькій
лікарні він пробув до обміну який
відбувся 29 червня мені зробили знімки
аналізи все сказали що все погано не
лікувати не будемо щоб додому
поверталися каліками ну всьо щоб встрой
сразу сталось
прижилась справжня пекло ще у перший
день російського вторгнення 24 лютого
22-го року я попала під ракетний обстріл
і
була поранена у нас вижило Три чоловіка
загиблі
Наші військовослужбовці і це все було на
очах
і це саме було тяжко бо це було Перший
день коли нас
бомбили і за цього начались у мене
паничні атаки ще Ну і дуже напруження
було
від каждого що руху як говориться Ну
конечно вже рік пройшов але воно завжди
це тяжко переноситься і пам'ять не
зітреш як говорить час лікує але не знаю
як це воно Ну до сих пор не відлікувало
працювати з травмою олені допомагають
психологи та коні тут ти відходиш від
всіх оцих від війни в першу чергу оці
півгодини що ми займаємось на конях це
от іменно що це якесь мир настає і в
душі і
хочеться щоб таку всіх було курс
іпотерапії складається з 10 занять для
Віктора Олени це вже 9 і спеціалісти які
супроводжують їх протягом курсу кажуть
що іпотерапія позитивно вплинула на
їхній стан тому програму вирішили
продовжити але в перспективі без
фінансової допомоги не обійтися наразі
ми закінчуємо
курс реабілітації першого потоку
військовослужбовців уже на черзі запуск
другої групи програма реалізується за
кошти благодійного фонду
військово-морських сил України в планах
розлучити якомога більше партнерської
підтримки ресурсу проєкт планують
розширити аби допомогти якомога більшій
кількості військових
[музика]